what's the next thing they want to ask
they want to know okay well how long
does it take to get from here the
release down to where it hits the ground
and then it bounces okay so what's the
time let's see it from here yeah hmm now
where would you go what direction would
you go we've got six equations to choose
from right I want to know how long it
takes take the ground so what's your
first instinct what you crazy
yeah yeah good I'm gonna take this one
right the thing about this point is that
it's on the ground where why is it equal
to zero
I don't know it's x value I could work
it out but I need to know the Y value
first okay so I'm gonna solve for this
is a this is a this is B I'm gonna solve
for y equals zero okay so you can have a
look at this when you put zero on this
side okay you're gonna get a quadratic
forty okay now it looks a bit gross
because you got these trig functions in
it but stay with it and you see what
happens so I've got zero
I'll put zero on the right-hand side
I've got minus 5t squared minus 42 seven
plus two point four it's all equal to
zero okay getting rid of that video sign
out the front but I'm like this rather
is 40 t sign seven I'm gonna write as 40
side seven and slap the team on the end
okay I hope you'll see why in a second
and there's that two point four hanging
over there now I know you say that when
you see a quadratic now I know that who
could we see quadratics we say always
try don't go to the formula first try
factorize no try you know something
don't trying to eat with this okay so
because of that trig function and stuck
there in the middle it makes a look
worse but it's just a constant so we can
do with it just like any other case so
this jump straight into the quadratic
formula
equal to minus B now so I want that
coefficient that's why I wrote it on its
own there and separated from the tape
minus B plus or minus the square root of
b squared minus 4ac okay so there's my a
and there's my C all right there's the
distribute of all divided by 2a which in
this case is all right now at this point
you have to write this in full okay
specifically you have to include the
postman us because if you're solving a
quadratic equation you're gonna have two
solutions okay my next line is to
disregard one of the solutions namely
the one where I've got a negative at the
front and then I've got a minus sign in
there why good so I'm gonna say T is
greater than zero that's my reason for
disregarding a solution okay
so minus 4t plus and this becomes
as this advice okay so disregarding the
negative negative
all right now it looks terrible but can
you calculator out a sign of 40 sign
seven - you know whatever pruning rule
you like and then give it a good yeah I
think the number I what that was
so there's my value to 0.01 seconds I
think that's the Acura City Hospital
okay now just pause for a minute does it
make sense as a as a value to seem
consistent three seconds it does I mean
the first person says well that's really
small but then you need to remember whoa
it's going really fast okay and if
you've acted games are cricket games are
quick enough slow I know but this flight
is not that slow okay so 0.36 is a
really sneakers now the next thing they
didn't ask for is the angle at which you
hit pitch that's that's sort of this
angle here okay so how you work out at
that angle call it
feedback we were asking the same
question we were looking at them in the
tank right what do we what information
do we need to work out that angle yes
good good so at this point here right
I'm gonna have a little tangled okay I
can work out impact speed and velocity
I'm sorry to speed of lawsuit speed and
angle right I get that and then I can
use all of it out okay we want to do it
in reverse so I want to know X naught
and why don't know the reason why I
asked that so you know which equations
are going to go through a second some of
which I just rubbed off okay so we're
gonna take next door and why not this is
I think I must be able to see that okay
and work out what they are now we'll do
X dot first okay me because X dot is
actually the same throughout the whole
scenario it doesn't change it over CL
acceleration on it okay
so what's next I think we said it was 40
College seven okay tuck that away for a
second
now why don't what's our equation for y
dot I think this was minus 10t it's just
plus or minus minus is dropping - 47
okay so in order to work out what this
is that's just the closer okay but I
need to know the time well that's kind
of handy because I just pointed out
right so not only should you have had 40
sine seven popped into your calculator
so you can actually work out what that
is but once you arrive at your point 3 5
9 6 ba ba ba ba ba maybe you want to
save that as well
so then when we pop it in here who can
actually get an exact answer
sure let's see so I'm gonna say yes
okay so this is actually just calculator
work in some senses so always you know
what values you're after evaluate them
to get them into your calculator think
we've got watch I'll wait
you see if you guys get me into because
I wait this out already see so we can
get it be careful with your brackets as
well you get there first
some of a number I give you a clue
starts with a zero that was a big clue I
know
got it he's got it to 1 to 1 and so on
okay all right now this is tan theta so
in order to get feet up you're gonna
have to say tan inverse right so I think
I got sorry yeah I hear at 12 in 12
degrees they only want it to the closest
degree and that's negative now why is it
negative because the balls coming down
right there's the angle that I'm
interested in okay now by the way just
be careful this is the angle of the
horizontal sometimes you're gonna be
seeing something that's vertical okay
so you might get this answer but if I
was hitting something vertical the angle
of the aft would be 78 right because
they're at right angles to each other
okay should you be careful what they're
actually asking for all right last
question I think it must be okay they
want to know it's a it's really phrased
you got your batsman here cuz that's
what all bats with all their bats like
and they're saying that he's I think say
19 meters away something like that
anyway he's that far away they're
interested in whether this ball lands at
a position less than greater than 5
meters away from them okay if it lands
really far away what's gonna happen is
it's going to bounce and because it
bounces certain early it'll come up
really high
okay so they caught that a short pitched
ball because it's really short on the
pitch so in five minutes it's just kind
of arbitrary okay so how can we work out
where it lands where are we gonna go I
want my horizontal here sort of corner
right so my X equation was 40 to7 or 40
plus 7 okay
so again you're gonna need to get that
value that you popped into your
calculator when you multiply it out well
yet
something about it this is a simpler one
yeah yeah good wait two to nine okay now
when you read the question you've got in
front of you question 12 D right I think
they say if it lands five meters away
from him so I guess that would be what
they're looking for is is it within five
meters or is it further so within five
meters you would have to land a fourteen
right so it lands at fourteen point two
nine so it's actually past that that
range we're gonna be short pitched so
the answer is no it's not okay so
sometimes they'll give you these kind of
arbitrary numbers and see if you can
interpret some value one of the simple
or the six equations to work out does it
fit what is it